foreign
[Music]
by two not here it's not
hey Dylan yoga instructor's in the gym
now
well I just noticed you're not getting
enough legs under your shot are you
dehydrated 100 bucks you can't make more
shots let's just do 300. it's not my
dad's money
they ain't never gonna get a reparation
that way bro so I prefer vimo or Zell
but you seem like a cash app guy so
ladies and gentlemen
see you think they're slick huh what's
showing up the course dressed like a
dumbass acting like you can't who you
assumed I couldn't move because I'm
white which is incredibly outdated I
assumed you couldn't hoop because you
were dressed like a white girl at Whole
Foods
it's really hard to plan for the future
when we're always worried about money
because you're out here living in a
fantasy my 30-day detox program going to
free sample no I ain't drinking no
boo-boo juice babe it's almost the first
I'm gonna go tomorrow I forgot why don't
you just go now it'll be fine don't
worry mommy don't worry about me every
Hooper I know is entering that big ass
tournament with a winner get five
hundred thousand I just need somebody
who can play so I can make some money
be joking right 500 000 for one day I
hope yeah yeah yeah we could hustle a
few games together to get the money for
the entry fee I'll find some marks those
short shorts look incredible throw them
off their game we have the only place
and we'll clean up you're gonna wear
that trash bag you can wear that fake
ass Richard Simmons outfit
bro I bet you all got more in common and
he's been uh release for me
release for me
don't spend any money until we can cover
the feet I should be saying that to you
but I'm good with money so am I so am I
me too me too where where bro
let alone go
what just wanted to see if you had
superhuman hearing because of you cause
my what
they're gonna kill him in the parking
lot I'm out of here he got a
flamethrower flamethrower what is this
Mad Max
you talking your ass laid in today good
work thank you you can talk way more
trash out there you have so much
material I can't even touch
like what
never mind oh
tell us what a Love Goes
foreign
[Music]